In today's challenge episode:
We're going to attempt
the unreturnable serve
See if hearing
affects ping pong
and more!
Let's get into it!
Three table tic-tac-toe
Let's go!
Yes!
No!
I need one more
Oooooh!
I need the back one
You got the middle
I have two chances
You have three chances!
Oooooh!
You took it from me!
Come on!
Thank you!
Good game!
That was fun!
The idea is to serve a serve
so short
that it bounces
onto the metal part
and rolls
on the table!
Easy peasy!
Ten tries?
10 000 tries
Oh!
Miikka, I think it's still bouncing there
Now you see
what we are trying!
Come and join the fun
of trying the impossible serve!
All this effort
just to get a net serve!
Come on Michael!
You can do it!
I think I need the good luck gong
Lunatic!
THE GONG WORKED!
We were almost losing it
after 90 minutes
You didn't even need
the chocolate break
No!
We have this challenge
where we build
the biggest chocolate racket
If we hit 5 million subscribers
Yes!
There's a fly!
It's not there anymore!
Let's try to swat
some ping pong balls!
It's like a badminton racket
Okay!
Should we move on
to the electric swatter?
Oh!
Anybody has water?
I think I've read in the school that
that's not the best combination?
But we'll see...
Bouncy ball plus
world's spinniest table
I think I need my bandana for this
I've just washed my hair
so it's all fluffy and in my eyes
Don't lie, Miikka
You never wash your hair
Okay!
The bounce is hard!
Whoa!
Yes!
That was dangerous!
Nobody in this hall is safe
We haven't tried the spin yet
Wooh!
How did it bounce that way?
Put a bit more spin
Oh, that's good!
We're going to need some safety equipment
for the next challenge
Safety first!
Otto, why does this sound like
Sensei racket on steroids?
I boosted it!
Let's go!
Okay!
I'm a bit scared
I'm terrified!
Yes!
They are playing surprisingly well
I try between the legs
Do not try this at home!
Or anywhere else either!
Wow!
Okay!
Coming!
Oih!
Whoa!
Got it!
Still got it!
Oih!
I think we're done
Let's go find out
how they are feeling...
after this!
It was actually really fun!
And it was a really good exercise
You can skip all the jogging and
you can just go play
table tennis in a truck!
Let's move on to the next challenge
So the idea is to get one shot on
then go one meter back...
Another shot
One meter back
I think six should be possible
Eight is realistic
Four meters!
Let's show Lassi
what we are made of!
Let's prove him wrong!
One meter
Two
Three?
Are you Otto sure?
Eight meters?
Yeah!
I feel like I've got the distance
One!
Two!
Three!
Four!
Five!
Good save!
Six!
Seven!
Eight?
Awwww!
Crazy dive!
One
Two
Three
Four
Five
Six
Seven!
And?
Eight!?
Yeah, we got it!
Eight meters!
Almost
Seven and a half
Okay, so we're going to try
to play table tennis
without hearing at all
So we're going to put ear plugs
and earmuffs on
and see how that affects gameplay
I can't hear much but...
I can still hear the high pitched noises!
So the next phase
is to have some wireless
headphones
I'll even put the music as loud as possible
I have to speak very loudly
so that I can hear myself!
Woah!
This is opening like
a new world to me!
I don't think it affects so much
the gameplay!
But it's just a cool experience!
Vision with only one eye
so half vision
Oh!
I kind of like need to face more here
The final stage
is to try them both!
*Hits a bird*
*Hits a drone*
*Hits a plane*
It's just edge, edge, edge!
Can I try?
Otto, don't say anything
if you agree:
That I'm a much better player than you?
Well, and he even nodded!
It's so hard!
So we need to recreate
Edward Scissorhands
and it's going to be...
Emil Paddlehands
Why are we doing this?
That's a very good question!
I'm going to have nightmares
from that!
Okay!
Serve?
Oh!
Wait a second!
Ahhh!
Much better than the previous one
Ready for this, Emil Paddlehands?
I'm ready!
Woah!
You should get the all
You have enough rackets
This is tough!
Like, surprisingly tough!
I think we can draw the conclusion
that it's not an advantage
to have six rackets
I think it's time to try
what I was born to do...
Emil Paddlehands
with six paddles on his fingers
He had one goal:
Six shots on
at the same time!
Proving the world
they're wrong!
That was his only mission
Everybody said he wouldn't become
a table tennis player
Get off the table!
Boo!
He had the motivation
And it's all come down to this day